- [Announcer] Ferrari.
Lamborghini.
Simply the ultimate in
vehicular luxury, right?
Well, in Italy, Lamborghini
started out associated
with tractors.
So how did Lamborghini evolve
from tilling the fields
of Bologna to becoming one
of the top luxury brands
on the planet?
Through a personal insult
delivered by this man.
Mr. Ferrari himself.
- Ferruccio Lamborghini was
a real man with real skills.
As an Italian Air Force
mechanic during World War II,
he set up a little auto
repair shop in Northern Italy,
buying surplus military machines
and converting them into tractors.
He made a lot of money.
- So much money
that he could finally
afford a Ferrari 250 GT,
a true sign that he had made it.
(car engine roaring)
But there was a problem.
So he took a trip to visit Enzo
Ferrari himself to complain.
Ferrari, notorious for
writing off his customers,
threw shade at the tycoon tractor maker,
exclaiming, "The problem
is not with the car,
but with the driver.
Go focus on your tractors."
Game on.
Lamborghini was furious
about Ferrari's fiery affront
and decided to build his own car,
just to spite him.
Lamborghini poached a few
of Ferrari's ex-employees
and told them to get to work
on beating their former boss
at his own game.
The team succeeded,
with the result being
the Lamborghini 350 GT.
And the rest is history.
- (speaks in foreign language)
- I already said that.